you
hi welcome before I introduce our guest
speaker for today I want to begin by
expressing my deep gratitude and thanks
to Paul ice and the center for the arts
society and to the School of Drama for
their ongoing support and sponsorship of
the performance and ecology project and
prove it today's lecture that project
has produced a number of events over the
last four years including a panel on
greening the future of live performance
and if it's pratik Oh drama festival and
it is going to culminate next year with
three major events first the devising of
an eco performance led by guest director
and demora in the fall second the
publication of an anthology titled
readings and performance in ecology
co-edited by myself and my colleague
Theresa May at the University of Oregon
which is coming out from palgrave next
spring and finally the hosting of the
Third Earth matters on stage symposium
here at CMU in June 2012 it's a lots of
exciting stuff coming up as director of
that project it has been my aim over the
last three years to call attention to
the power of performance to raise
awareness about ecological issues to
stimulate activism build coalitions and
move and inspire spectators to action
and more than any other scholar I can
think of our guest today professor d so
uni Madison exemplifies those goals I
first became aware of professor
medicines work when my own scholarship
took an ethnographic turn in the
mid-2000s and
picked up her book critical ethnography
this insightful work not only outlines a
theory and method for translating
ethnographic data to the public stage
but also argues persuasively that
scholars and artists can exercise
principles of advocacy and engaged
ethics through a public staging of the
photography what she calls a critical
performance of nog raphy her most recent
book in 2010 acts of activism human
rights and radical performance amplifies
this theory and methodology and also
presents three case studies in acts of
activism that exemplify how performance
is employed in the defense of Human
Rights and the actualization of social
justice professor Madison's writing here
as in for earlier work bridges
scholarship artistic practice and
activism in the past decade alone she
has researched devised co-written and
directed performance pieces on subjects
ranging from the oral histories of
workers at the University of North
Carolina to the life and work of Nelson
Mandela to the complicated and volatile
debates surrounding the practice of
troco see which is a form of ritual
servitude in Ghana in which women and
girls are indentured to religious
shrines in reparation for crimes
committed by members of their family her
work on water rights and the political
economy of water which you will share
with us today lingual the scholarship
and her activism to both ecological
issues and questions of environmental
justice her research documents
connections between globalization local
governmental policies privatization and
environmental degradation as root issues
in the fight for water democracy in
Ghana and the performances she the
performance that she developed out of
that research makes those connections
heartfelt and real for performers and
audience members in the United States
most of whom have the privilege of
taking the availability of
abundant water holy for granted one of
the things I admire most about professor
Madison's work is the way that she
continually foregrounds and interrogate
her own positionality as my only
investigator and researcher but as a
human being with a deep
interconnectedness to the human beings
whose lives she witnesses she brings her
doubts about her rights and
responsibilities as a witness recorder
and analysts to life at every turn
encouraging us as readers and spectators
to reflect similarly on our own
connectedness rights and
responsibilities visa meet others
professor Madison's research and
activism has been recognized in the form
of numerous awards including the Tanner
University award at Chapel Hill for
outstanding and inspirational teaching
the National Communication Association
spotlight on scholars the J William
Fulbright senior scholar award and a
Rockefeller Foundation villaggio
research award she's published five
books as well as articles in leading
journals like performance research the
Journal of cultural studies and textin
performance quarterly among others and a
particular interest to me was to see
that she has also added her voice to the
contemporary US political debate in
essays on Michelle Obama angry post
black women and crazy patriotism
professor Madison is a model of
activists engaged ecologically mindful
scholarship and artistic practice please
join me in warmly welcoming her to
Carnegie Mellon
you
my compliments to most def this is one
of the scenes from our production at
Chapel Hill water rights this afternoon
I will share with you what happens when
ethnography and performance conjoined to
dramatize the political economy of water
I will show moments from two locations
my fieldwork in Ghana with local water
activists and scenes from the
performance water rights presented at
unc-chapel Hill in march two thousand
six its Wayne Hall my work in recent
years more organically than by design
makes economy theatrical and makes
politics more about effect than argument
I don't set out to make a political
performance like most of us I set out to
make a performance about those things I
care about about those things I most
care about happen to be ethnic rafic and
content forum tone and imagination this
means both honoring and taking refuge in
the small story like my small microphone
that I have to turn on there we go this
means both honoring and taking refuge in
the small story my father who was a
labor union activists and Chicago used
to say that you must find meaning first
in the small William Blake's famous
dictum that you can see the world in a
grain of sand in the contested space of
ethnographic inquiry there are myriad of
small stories located in the everyday
all of them constituted by a political
economy a constitution that I cannot
ignore because if I ignore it I cannot
tell the story those micro moments
within the everyday the god of small
things daily rituals of belonging
symbolic acts of resistance customary
gestures of affection and the small
story circling within other small
stories ancient and new
written and told that bring that only
flesh blood and bone two discourses of
democracy globalization and empire but
they bring extended dimensions of
accuracy specificity and passion to the
macro economies of global networks my
work explores how the performative of
spelt sensing bodies and small stories
can unlock the material reality as much
as sometimes more than explorations of
superstructure of governance state and
nation so when I talk about a political
economy of water or a political economy
of performance I am obviously talking
through fucose well no notion when he
says quote the control of society over
individuals is not conducted only
through consciousness of Audiology but
also in the body and with the body for
capitalist society biopolitics is most
important the biological the somatic the
corporeal the social body is comprised
by powers machine and developed in its
virtuality so the water rights
performance must be a process of putting
flesh onto the issues of water we are
performing embodied knowledge 'as about
water this according to bryan alexander
quote means or reflects that the body as
a conduit of being the body as the
materiality of presence the body as the
nexus of need and the body as a site of
knowing from board you to merleau-ponty
to sarah ahmed the body knows and feels
and does beyond being sarah ahmed states
quote bodies do not dwell in space that
are exterior but rather are shaped by
their dwelling and take shape in
dwelling spaces are not exterior two
bodies instead spaces are like a second
skin that unfolds in the folds of the
body therefore the creation accumulation
and distribution of wealth not
only affects the operations of nations
and stories but the small embodied
intimate spaces that shelter us how we
make our food dress ourselves let to
labour choose who we love remember our
past and create our futures and how we
make culture in this day and age can you
be an economist without some basic
understanding of culture and how it is
produced can you be a cultural critic
and maker without some basic
understanding of economics and the
processes of political economy the show
water rights this was the confrontation
these were the facts the fact is that
more than 1 billion people lack access
to clean affordable water about 2
billion people lack access to sanitation
the fact is that in the urban areas of
Ghana only forty percent of the
population has a water tap that is
flowing seventy eight percent of the
poor and urban areas do not have piped
water the fact is the treated water is
available only to about sixty five
percent in urban areas and only about
thirty five percent in rural areas the
fact is that waterborne diseases kill
one child every eight seconds and that
in sub-saharan Africa almost seventy
percent of deaths and disease are due to
the lack of clean and accessible water
the majority of women and children in
rural areas travel miles in the morning
and evening for water that remains
infected with waterborne diseases the
World Health Organization's daily
requirement for water is 20 to 40 litres
a day per person in Ghana for those
without a piped water system purchasing
three buckets or 18 litres a day can
cost between ten to twenty percent of
their daily income the fact is that over
five million people in a year die from
illnesses linked to unsafe drinking
water unclean domestic environments and
improper sanitation they are mostly
under five years of age at any time over
half the population of the developing
world
suffers from diseases associated with
water and sanitation the performance
water rights the posters and
announcements for water rights described
it as a multimedia performance on the
politics and poetics of water water
rights explored water activism and our
human relationship with water through a
montage of digital imagery comic satire
dramatic monologue and stylized movement
water rights reflected how we all
perform water rights in our everyday
lives and how these rights variously
pervade our culture beautifully happily
and tragically water rights perform the
questions what is our first memory of
water does anyone have the right to own
water our water wars still taking place
in the 21st century what is the
connection between local water and
global profit included in the
announcements for the show was the
famous or infamous 1995 quote from a
former president of the World Bank quote
if the water wars of the 20th century
were fought over oil the wars of this
century will be fought over water
unquote I hope the performance would
inspire and disturb the audience and a
group of performers relative to the
quest for water and how the lack of it
pervades the everyday lives of countless
individuals on this planet I hope to
build a performance community because
water rights was as much a pedagogical
experiment for this group of students as
it was a staged performance for an
audience therefore the end product of
the show would be only as good as what
my students learned about water and how
well and how deeply they felt they
learned it together this meant my
students must have a love affair with
water during the performance process
they must acquaint themselves with water
anew and differently with feelings of
reverence and believing that water is
precious they must emotionally
emotionally learn to love water
and even more they must care about how
each other learn to love water be the
before they could truthfully perform
what is ultimately about the political
economy of water public water / private
water water as a human right over water
as an economic good the local donkey
cart seller / corporate business now I
want to share excerpts from the show
water rights while weaving those
excerpts with field work in Ghana and
moments from the rehearsal the video
rehearsal to
this was a video that we began our show
with and that began this particular
rehearsal moment
we are all
at birth the baby ate as a child grows
and becomes an adult the body is
comprised of 70 we are all watching why
are chips frequencies and vibrations
every cell and i pod contains one every
cell in our body is alignment by the
frequency and vibration some water we
are all one when water changes we change
when there is the one when it turns dry
when its clarity because stolen every
cell in our body will cry before that
before I can teach about the politics of
water I must teach about the spirit of
water before there is politics I really
believe there is a soul we are all water
and water is all of us water is living
changing and responsive to believe this
is the purpose of rehearsal too there
are 18 of us we are all sitting together
on the floor in a large circle the room
is dark on the floor in front of each of
us is a candle the only light in the
room is a flame from each of our candles
I ask the performers to breathe deeply
and look into the flame I say to them
feel the quiet in the room and focus on
the flame I look into the light of the
flame and how it moves against the
darkness I stop speaking and the room is
quiet we enjoy the quiet and the flame
for a few more seconds I look around and
they are focused making the transition
from the noisiness and busyness of their
daily self into this temporality of a
water right rehearsal I break the
silence I say please look into the flame
be still and just feel quiet now close
your eyes two of my assistant directors
for this show and the Siq lark and
Elizabeth Nelson be grint begin reading
passages from asaro motels the hidden
message of water they in that section
with this passage anissa sound and water
we are all water music affects the
frequency current fluctuation vibration
of water this means that sound effects
the frequency of water sounds affect the
cells in our body that are made up of
water Elizabeth we must recover our
desire to treat water with respect
anissa if we dialogue with water
lovingly and with respect water will
change
water in your body will change anissa
finally she says we must pay respect to
water feel love and gratitude and
receive vibrations with a positive
attitude then water changes you change
and I change because both you and I are
water I asked the actors to open their
eyes and share a word or phrase that
impress them that's stuck with them and
that they will want to remember when all
have spoken I will conclude the
rehearsal by asking them to read from
their journal assignment on memory and
their first discovery or recognition of
water it is my turn now I am now reading
from my journal notes I am my most
vulnerable ever as a teacher when I read
to my students from my field notes I
read now and they listen how they are
listening at this moment what they feel
what they think I simply cannot gauge at
all I continue reading shaking and
scared trying to gather the confidence
that however they are receiving what I
read at this moment it is my experience
and it is true and deeply dear to me and
above all necessary for them to know
journal entries September 10 1998 a day
at the market I was standing at the tro
tro stop trying to get a bus back home
it was so hot that day I'm in Accra
Ghana I can hardly breathe and nothing
could quench the thirst every trotro
that pass by was filled with people
packed together crushed inside trying to
get where they needed to go a stream of
dilapidated old vans full of exhaust
fumes sweaty bodies overbearing heat and
the smells the smells everything felt so
crowded and so dirty that day so dirty I
was hot and tired and missing my home in
the US and feeling very much like The
Ugly American as I waited hoping a tro
tro would
so I could squeeze into one empty seat
and get back to the quiet and solitude
of my flat at lagan I looked down the
road a bit and saw a woman she was
sitting over a bucket of soapy water
there was a child at her feet she
undressed the child and then placed him
in the bucket of water she was bathing
the child in the public market place
quiet and solitude for her are a
different reality than they are for me I
was transfixed by what was more than
just a woman bathing a child outside in
a hot crowded market but how the
ordinary how the day today is so strong
and impeccably resilient against the
fact of its own reality as I watched the
woman and child suddenly an old man
appeared to be mad he appeared to be mad
his hair was all matted he was half
dressed with very dirty very dirty
clothes and he walked up to the woman
and the child without the least concern
she simply brushed him away with the
wave of her hand and to continue to
bathe the child the man undeterred
filthy very filthy and dirty stumbled
toward the bucket and began taking off
his clothes and he attempted to step
into the soapy water with the baby
immediately two young men standing next
to me at the troll troll stopped quickly
walked over to the old man and with such
sincere gentleness and gracious respect
help the man put his clothes on and then
guided him down the road the woman
paying no mind to the old man no mind to
anyone or anything around her kept her
wilful attention on her child and their
ritual for much of the global South
specifically Africa dirt is a fact and
assemble dirty people having dirty
children with dirty faces wearing dirty
clothes the white
stated quote labeling someone or
something dirty is a way of controlling
perceived anomalies incongruity zeeeee
contradictions and buggy eyes all that
does not fit into our categories and
therefore threatens cherish principles
dirt then functions as the mediating
term between as Mary Douglas states
difference and danger unquote we know
that dirt is to be gotten rid of but we
tend to forget the dirt will dwell while
water is inaccessible nor do we
sometimes remember that when sanitation
systems are impaired or non-existent
dirt embraces disease the other bodies
the lolz some bodies the dirty bodies
the disfigured bodies the sick body the
body that smells of refuge the body that
oozes excretes and cannot shelter its
waste the bodies grotesquely out of
place of the bodies that wrenching
poverty will breed in its abominable
lack discuss and circles these bodies
with visceral loathing and fear fear of
nearness and the threat of contamination
loathing for the failure of these bodies
to keep themselves out of sight dirt is
a factor of economic and political
conditions but as a tactical deflection
is generally cast as a moral flaw but in
this small moment on a hot day in a
crowded African market a woman bathes
her child a water right real and
resistant the performance Abraham
the performance section and title
Abraham you can turn it down a little
bit you actually go this is footage I
took of my field work at a pond one day
I was trying to hold the camera steady
but I was stumbling because the ground
was uneven and the water was very muddy
and it was hard to get my balance the
performance section ebrahim focuses on a
young donkey cart seller at a pond in a
town called salve elugu located in
northern Ghana the purpose of this
segment was to personalize young men who
sell water by situating them as subjects
within their own story and their own
individual history the dunk ecard seller
is a composite character named ibrahim
ibrahim gives us a glimpse of what it
means to sell water from the back of a
donkey I wrote the Ibrahim monologue
from information and experiences
gathered in the field over the years
pertaining to donkey cart sellers guinea
worm and how families managed to the
perils of water access
it was intended to more fully narrate
and imagine the inner lives of those who
sell water at the backs of donkeys and
the consequences of their labor
I'm now at the edge of the pond quite
close to the donkey and trying to hold
so it's so jumpy I apologize for that
projected on to large screens are for
sequential images from photographs I
took one day at the palm of a young
donkey cart seller and the video ebrahim
needs a boy about the age of fourteen
years in various images you'll see after
this video in various images he stands
with his donkey each image fades into
the next as a following monologue is
performed the character Ibrahim stands
on a platform just below the screen his
shadow is cast over half the screen
you can see the labor and care they're
taking and closing and concealing and
sealing those barrels and you can also
see the color of the water and imagine
the added labor when that water is sold
and it's cleaned and purified at home
and you can also see the labor of the
poor donkey as well
you
okay who's up the water flying out of
the barrels you can you can actually
stop that and move on to the next one so
they actually start again in terms of
putting water in the second barrel ok
this is the Ibrahim monologue the boy
Ibrahim enters a platform up stage left
Ibrahim my name is ibrahim i'm from sab
elugu i am 14 years old and I sell water
I am what the people call a donkey cart
water seller I go down to the pond every
day with my donkey and I fetch water my
younger brother goes with me we travel
about five miles every day back and
forth to the pond we sell water to the
people here there are other donkey cart
water sellers but we are the best some
of the old people and the sick people
can't carry the water or walk to fetch
it and the people who take care of them
are too busy the pond is too far
sometimes the pond will dry up and we
have to search for water my brothers and
me are very very happy because we have
our own donkey we are blessed to have
this donkey we get up in the morning
before the Sun and we get a rope and we
tie the rope too many many buckets
around the donkey's back then we start
our first walk to the pond me my brother
and the donkey get inside the pond where
the water is full and plenty my brother
fills up the bowls and pours water in
the bucket that we have fastened to the
donkey's back I hold the donkey very
very carefully so the donkey won't slide
and fall down and spill the water back
into the pond the water is heavy my
brother pores and pores and I hold on
when the buckets are filled and my
little brother's back his tire
we leave the pond we start the journey
with our donkey to sell water to the
people who need it when the water is
sold we go back to the pond and we start
all over again I hold on to the donkey
and my brother fills up the buckets we
fetch water from the pond about four to
six times a day my mother worries that
my brother and me will get the guinea
worm from the water many people around
here have gotten guinea worm from the
water but we have not gotten any guinea
worm not yet my mother has guinea worm
and my little sister my little sister
was sick for a long time you are very
blessed when you don't get guinea worm
because you can keep working and
fetching water and making money to live
they pull the worm out of my little
sister's leg and in a few days she felt
better oh it was a long big guinea worm
it looked longer and bigger than my
sister's leg my mother said she could
not fetch water anymore so it's just my
brother and me if I get guinea worm I
will worry who will hold the donkey my
mother told me when she was a young girl
they had plenty plenty water water
flowed from the pipes from the pipes
every day now she said they bathed and
wash and drank and never got sick no
tire back no guinea worm no worry when
my mother was a young girl fresh clean
water flow from the pipes but not
anymore Vandana Shiva says we know that
two percent of the people on this planet
use eighty percent of the earth's
resources this means that eighty percent
of the world's population are not
receiving their just share because of
that two percent unquote
the field 2004 Accra Ghana the World
Water Forum my friend Al Hasan Adam
attended the World Water Forum in 2003
in Kyoto Japan to represent Ghana and
its coalition against water
privatization there was scheduled to be
a very important keynote presentation
given by the former IMF managing
director the representative was
scheduled to launch a report that
basically entailed according to Al Hasan
quote how to finance water the report
was intended to focus on quote how the
private sector can now go to public
funds and then use public funds to
finance water unquote there were anti
privatization activists from all over
the world Asia Latin America Africa
Europe and the United States when they
found out in advance about the report
they decided they must do something
about it Al Hassan said quote we were
really a rainbow unquote on the eve of
the keynote the activists held their own
meeting and decided to protest the world
bank report how were all of you going to
protest the report I asked him he says
in the big meeting hall where all where
the report was to be given they were
going to be high officials and important
people it was organized by the world
water Council one of the Japanese
ministers from water was there the South
African minister for water and forest
ministers and development ministers and
everybody was there who was supposed to
matter the water chief executives water
activists water technocraft technocrats
everybody was going to be there so we
activists had to dress very very well we
could not get into the hall and we could
not look suspicious we did not want them
to be aware of our plan unquote so you
dressed up like them I asked him and it
was a disguise so they wouldn't
recognize all of you as activists
exactly he said we made live meter
to stage our protest we hid them under
our coats so as we entered the hall no
one could see them I was amused I said
live meters yes set out the Sun the live
meters were made out of cardboard we
painted a red orange and brown arc on
each meter attached to the bottom of the
meter were small bells there were about
five of us who went into the hall with
the live meters under our coats we stood
in five different sections so they would
be so we would be at strategic points in
the room when the World Bank fellow read
his report each time he told a lie all
of us would shake the meter and point
the arrow in the direction of one of the
colors for the small eyes the meter
would shake and go to brown for the
bigger lies the meter would shake and go
to yellow for the biggest lies the meter
would shake and go to read we had a
fellow who signaled the color and the
time to point in order to be sure we
were all shaking at the same time and on
the same point one of the protesters
would shine a light on him and he would
then signal to us to shake and move the
meter on the color all five of us would
move the meter at the same time and on
the same color did anyone try to stop
you did did they speak to you did they
try to stop you in any way el Hassan
shook is that no they couldn't they were
shocked they were just absolutely
shocked well did them did the World Bank
guy did he finish his speech he started
to fumble Al Hassan said the Japanese
Minister tried to persuade us to stop
then he said we must speak to the issues
we spoken to the microphone and we began
asking questions and speaking to the
issues of privatization we had six
people station and there were two Mike's
three people at one side of the mic and
three people at the other side of the
mic we really prepared and we did our
homework for this we knew what we were
doing we had met and we had planned and
we had
rehearsed our presentation very very
carefully we let them know that all of
us there we represent so many people and
you people are not representing anybody
anymore on the count of all these lies
you're telling we want to have a
dialogue we did not come here to just
listen to a report being read to us
after all this report to one year to
prepare and this is the first time we
are hearing it so we want a dialogue
said Allison they said we'll give you 15
minutes we we are given you 15 minutes
we said you can't use one year to ride
report and give us 15 minutes to respond
to it he said this is not fair and this
is not democratic we denounce the
meeting and we denounce your report we
don't recognize your report this was a
historic moment I said what happened
next we had two big banners he said it
said people before profit and water
cannot be sold we went to the stage and
covered the front of the stage with the
banners and we started chanting water
for life not for profit and then we just
covered the whole platform nobody sees
them again unquote the protest at the
World Water Forum becomes a genealogical
thread and testament of a political
beginning expressed through performance
and as a method of intervention and
praxis al Hassan's narrative is another
contribution to how performance in
politics become reciprocal partners in
generating and narrating the social
consequences of a community of
individuals and how in turn these
individuals and communities make more
performances in the continuum in
spiraling forward of social justice the
performance at the World Water Forum was
powerful because it was tactical at
several levels first it relied heavily
on surprise for its effectiveness
surprise held a two-fold purpose here it
was both a tactic and a maneuver to
assure the activists would get into the
space of the hall and it also was a
means to shock and therefore bring
greater attention to themselves surprise
also served as an important device
because it added to the quality of
spectacle by startling and jolting the
audience to an ex surprise is to harness
attention you can hardly look away at a
surprise when you are jolted your
attention is focused and captured by the
jolt they needed to shock the audience
into entirely different register and
mode of attention than what the audience
expected to happen and what was
happening before they entered the hall
without this initial shock it would have
been more difficult to punctuate the
moment as al-hasan stated the activists
wanted the big shots attending the
meeting to be caught unawares to
ironically could provoke them into the
greatest possible awareness of their
presence through surprise second in
succeeding to surprise the audience the
element of shock was complemented by a
theatrics of inversion the group of
actor activists literally created a
reversal of positions relative to
controlling the discourse of water
privatization and how that discourse was
now framed the gentleman from the World
Bank who represents the most powerful
economic institution in the world was
now usurped by people who will most
likely never ever ever possess control
or manage an iota of the amount of
capital capital he deals with at the
bank the tenacity and will of the
activists displaced the speaker in an
act where subaltern voices silenced in a
particular moment in time a voice from
the high ground of world finance this
inversion that contributed to
globalization from below was no small
inversion maneuver the tactic also
inverted the form and content of the
discourse from speaker audience to
agitprop performance happening
full of the theatrics of costume props
queues dramatic effect and the passion
to reverse and reinvent power
arrangements third the inversion was
enabled by design a well-thought-out and
conceived plan for a specific function
and purpose the performance was
methodically arranged from the
coordination of what would be worn the
graphics of the lie meter the
synchronization of the ringing bells the
timing of the flash light cues the to
the climactic moment of mounting the
stage and dropping the man the batter to
literally and figuratively mask the
panel as they disappeared from sight and
sound under the excessive appearance and
boldness of the banner as both prop and
signification of water cannot be sold
the event and its components of surprise
and version and design transform the
diverse group of internationalists
activists into a momentary community of
mutually empowering comrades the
privatization ideology by the sheer
force of the performance was suspended
relinquishing the last word to the
activists the event unleashed the
possibility of more performance from
below to be remembered and revived
making ethnographic performance I have
stated that to create for the stage the
living performances of everyday
remembrances imaginings and deeply felt
encounter encounters of ethnographic
fieldwork is a radical act of
translation doing performance
ethnography is a radical act of
translation because it not only
constitutes the crisis of representation
the symbiotic relationship between macro
and micro forces the always unresolved
engagements with other pneus the
geopolitical gap between the ones will
freely come and go and the ones who stay
but all this and more must be translated
multi-dimensional II for the stage in
for the public
public translation of which the other
more than likely will never see and at
still another level of translation is
the factor of verisimilitude in the
labor of staging ethnography very
similar to buy replicant replication is
not the goal but how well the enliven
asst of the metaphor works this means
giving a nod to roman jakobson the idea
of replicating what happened in the
field must be replaced by the ideal idea
that the metaphor the performance is
actually comprised of and in fact can be
more accurately understood as a metal
nim i bring you but only an element to
represent a greater whole it is really
about the metonym and how well we can
represent embellish and honor elements
of the ethnographic world encapsulations
and their reverberations to make the
audience feel a sense of being present
within a greater whole therefore my
deepest ethical dilemma in staging
ethnographic data is not the absence of
the other who cannot be there to see the
show but how and by what means I can
make the audience who is there feel a
sense of being present with the other in
the others actual absence what metonymic
elements within the thick description of
ethnographic habitation and co
performance can I create to form a
metaphoric whole that represents the
other subjectivity and the formations of
that subjectivity subjectivity
beautifully memorably disturbingly to
the point where my audience feels
present with others in their world
moreover how can I create a performance
where the audience is both inspired and
disturbed by feeling being present in
that world this ethnographic sense of
presence is not the same but a
complement to theatrical presence a
shared temporality and aura a
vulnerability of a live in this
of being there together with the
performance this ethnographic present is
adding a reversal too theatrical
presence it all souls arguing here that
being present in this ethnographic sense
is something discreetly different than
empathy because it involves more than I
feel your pain it is the sense of being
transported to a place where you begin
to feel that you may actually have a
stake in the way the other world works
you feel you want to respond to it also
the sense of being present is not a mood
toward the dur idian metaphysics of
presence as a hierarchy of truth but
towards Shannon Jackson's a pivotal
moment were distinct pieces distinct
phenomena metonymic ontologies combined
and converged to momentarily transport
you to a time and space you have never
been before in a way that haunts you in
a way that you cannot shake it off it is
a utopian performative for me because
the audience feels the urge to react or
you hope they'll feel the urge to react
but should the sense of being present
prevail in making water rights there are
moments when the sense of being present
was actually disrupted by its opposite
the feeling of alienation it was the
dialectic between presence and
alienation that formed the mounting
rhythm of the show and that were
grounded in the power of juxtaposition
throughout the show various forms text
ideas opposites were positioned and
placed side by side to create a
different and new meaning and sensation
the side by side arrangements both
deconstructs and reconstructs through a
proximate of both nearness and contrast
what is different about an element is
they're emphasized by its nearness or
its closeness to its opposite yet it is
this very nearness that dissolves
separation by bringing them together in
the creation of something altogether new
for example it was important to present
the basic arguments against the
corporate privatization of water but I
did not want it to be didactic therefore
i use parody by creating a comic
character called mr. big this scene was
an assortment of juxtapositions while
the lofty and pompous mr. big was
boasting in his board room on the
virtues of corporate privatization
placed in juxtaposition directly above
his head and projected on the screen
stage right was a rather simple minded
obtuse PowerPoint demonstration entitled
three myths of privatization mr. big
pseudo-intellectual posturing against a
South morgue oversized PowerPoint
display was meant to illuminate the
hidden contradictions and convolutions
of water business or what water
activists call big water and to
deconstruct key jux justifications
giving by proponents of privatization
the second juxtaposition and more
dramatic was placing the funky poets
funky breakdown seen directly stage left
of mr. BIG's boardroom the funky funky
breakdown scene were a group of super
cool funky spoken word poet slamming mr.
BIG's corporate language and demeanor
one by one with their irreverent body
insults but just as physical
juxtaposition was employed there were
moments or psychological just
juxtaposition was also important one
example is a psychological binary with
within the inner world of the
ethnographer herself two actors
performed a kind of ambiguous
representation of me a kind of me and
not me if you will or more precisely
what we understand as a narrative I
and the narrative me these two
performers were placed side by side in
this particular scene as a recorder one
and recorder two are one was down States
indistinct speaking directly to the
audience and our two was upstaged out of
platforms speaking directly to our one
the physical juxtaposition underscored a
psychological juxtaposition with in the
binary of the ethnographic self that
nose and the ethnographic self that
questions her own knowing in this
instance self-reflexivity was performed
but even more the performance took on a
drama of inner conflict oneself battling
with the intention of the other self
this was the scene is taken from an
Christians launders water business
corporation versus people recorder one
in kwazulu-natal South Africa they
arrest mr. sulay and put him in prison
put him in a prison cell he had stolen
water what happened mr. seuly earned 100
random month selling water but
eventually he could not afford to pay
the water bill he also had to pay for
food and shelter for his family and
school fees for his children his family
needed water and he could no longer
stand by and watch his children beg for
it mr. Sewell I made an illegal
connection to the to the supply pike
when it was discovered the police came
and put him in jail what does mr. seuly
have to do with you what are you doing
here in Ghana it's about water I need to
know more I need to do water you need to
know you need to do what is it you need
to know you need to do there are big
people with big money who want to own
water and and they want to sell it
and they want to manage it and make a
profit and and there will be people who
cannot afford to pay for it oh but what
has that got to do with you nosy woman
stay out of other people's business
profit and privatization have always
been the twins of progress you know what
they say God provided the water but not
the pipes there will be people who
cannot afford to pay for it read my lips
water business management distribution
maintenance pipes pipes pipes water is
not free water cannot be owned water is
a public good the public will manage it
the public should profit from it the
public oho the public smuggling ha the
public in the developing world economies
oh that public has been very successful
so efficient so honest and so concerned
about the public good yes yes getting
water to all the people all the time
concerned about all its all its poor
citizens never an ounce of corruption or
water or just not knowing what the hell
they're doing yes leave it to the
government of these countries after all
they have done so well done so well you
do not understand you haven't been
paying attention to it it it is let me
explain to you the prob the problem is
the problem is the public sector has
done so well as the water pipes break
down everywhere as the water collectors
take money from the people and put the
money in their own pockets as the
government water companies overcharge
miss charged under charge or don't
charge for water they miss manage all
the while making a messy waste of
natural resources some people around
here haven't had water flowing from
their pipes and weeks and months you are
not looking below the surface you do not
know what you're talking about you do
not know anything it is more complex it
is much more complex oh it's more
complex it's much more complex maybe if
the big people come with their big plans
and their big money and their big pipes
in their big teams and their big big big
big promises maybe people in this
country can get some water clean fresh
efficient water you don't understand
really you don't understand what's going
on you are missing the point you just
don't understand then make me understand
help me understand tell me what I need
to know and do tell me the truth you are
taking up space and getting in the way
tell me what is the truth and what needs
to be done she is grasping the truth is
the problem it's if it's complex what is
complex I'm learning it's here I've got
to get to it i'm here i will be here
learn what you came here to learn don't
give me slogans and platitudes i am so
tired of slogans and platitudes can you
say something different about water can
you say something more recorder there is
no replacement for water no replacement
know what you came here to do and then
both recorder one and recorder to come
together there is more to know here and
I will be here I will be here I will
come to be here and we must understand
in conclusion if performance is about
anything it's about effective
truth a wonderful teacher once told me
that art is about making layers and
layers of truth in the interest of
emotion Margaret Thompson drool stated
that for the Yoruba artists beauty is
not as we conventionally define beauty
that is pleasing to the eye but it is
how close the art objects depict truth
however grotesque or frightening the
appearance if art pulls you into the
undercurrents of a deeply felt
recognition a profound and intricate
resolve however momentary then it is
beautiful because it is truthful it is
this combination of effect beauty and
truth that also helps me under unearth
the tyrannical side within claims and
truth regimes we know truth is
historical the greatest enemy of any one
of our truths may be the rest of our
true said William James I tore myself
away from the safe comfort of
certainties through my love for truth
and truth rewarded me said Simone de
Bouvier art and performance seeks truth
that is blasphemous George Bernard Shaw
said all great truths begins as
blasphemies ye shall know truth and the
truth shall make you mad aldous huxley
if art pulls you into a deeply felt
recognition a profound resolve it is
beautiful the combination of effect
truth and beauty means that these
stories and Ghana must travel the
performance ended with r1 and r2
complicating the power of truth the
small story and what is meant by the
ethnographic performance project and how
the ethnographic performance project is
always about a story that travels k into
the finals
in the vinyls in the very final scene
recorder one and recorder to come
together and contemplate this notion of
truth through travel as slides are shown
from scenes from Ghana recorder one
truth is elusive are too but it demands
our attention our one it doesn't stay in
one place or breathe inside one story
are too but it can we've got to find
those one places and those one stories
we've got to search truth demands our
attention in the multitudes of its
yearnings we've got to fight for it we
are not alone are one we can see and
listen deeply past the obtuse blindness
of appearances and the paralyzing
silence of too much noise are too deep
pass the lives reborn again and again by
the greedy and the lazy are one we will
search for truth in the multitude of the
one story are to the one story that is
always here and there and everywhere
details of life lived on the hard edge
blade of truths teeth are one it will
hurt it always does because truths blade
cuts deep deep at the skin and bone of
what it implies R 1 the implication are
two yes the implication that breaks your
heart and demands the search for more
truths more truth more are one do we
feel our hearts breaking from the teeth
are too sometimes but more than breaking
we feel our hearts swelling as if it is
about to burst open into flames are one
burst from what our to burst from the
fear and hope of finding the right
question to spark the right story that
will unleash an avalanche of truths are
one bursting from the fear and hope of
how we will carry these stories back so
they will not soften the teeth of truth
or dull its blade are too we are
bursting from how we will listen and
wrap words around the stories that we
must carry back our one back home are
two back here are one back everywhere
the words we wrap around truths teeth
will fly past us and carry themselves
beyond our reach we make retold stories
are one every retool story becomes a
travelling story retold far beyond the
presence of our own body are one we told
for truths sake to harm the teeth and
sharpen the blade yes our hearts are
bursting and not breaking from the
weight of the search the weight of the
question the implication but most of all
most of all from the weight of carrying
these truths truly are one yes beyond
our reaches and beyond the starting
point of the one true story are two and
you can go to water rights digital
pictures from the show we are not of
this place this is not our home are too
we live in the richest country in the
world are one this is a fact what should
we do about it are to use it like a
blade of fire against its own flame r
142 sake bar too yes and for the sake of
hearts on the verge of exploding r1 and
r2 yes and for the sake of hearts on the
verge of X
loading thank you these final slides are
slides from the actual show water rights
so you need about to work or
what
what I mean how to perform together
this is the question and how did I put
the performance team together for this
particular production and I announced
that I wanted to do a performance about
water and describe what I hope that
performance would look like in terms of
people wanting to most everybody knew
that I had been in Ghana all these years
doing this work on water rides so I put
posters and little bills all over the
performance studies department stating
that I wanted us to do a device
performance on water that would be
collaborative with me on my water on my
water field research and people came and
we we had a discussion one-on-one about
what the responsibilities of this would
be and those folks who wanted to be a
part of it we're partners
not everybody actually perform some
people some people say
yes two questions what was the running
time
the running time it was about an hour
and 45 minutes
and a couple of things that happened
I've had students who have gone on to
work with different water organizations
I've also had students who have decided
that they want to do this kind of device
performance around political issues
particularly doing field work and i also
have folks that are still contacting the
students from Chapel Hill and contacting
me about because in the program there
was a list of organizations that they
could join all right and we ask that
they check in with us if they wanted to
if they were still working with these
organizations what were some of their
experiences and I have gotten as well as
the students several folks that said
that they had gone on to join some of
these organizations this this
performance is also in a book the the
entire script and I get calls saying the
people are using some of those sections
in their classes and some of them are
also performing sections of them what I
wanted more than anything else was for
people to feel that if they wanted to do
something about this there were places
they were organizations there were
groups that were doing these kinds of
things and they could simply join those
or inquire but there there there is work
on this it's not that this performance
is the first or that those of us who are
part of this performance are inventing
this question all right and what I most
wanted to do was with our with our
performance participants the
collaborators I really wanted us to
build our own kind of community our own
kind of extended family all right and
that this would be a way for them to be
in this performance but it would also be
a kind of training ground for them to
continue this process of
device performance
how how long was your rehearsal process
and when did you start with everyone and
how long was that what all of this had
the sea during the boxes of four
treatments the lighting all that step
come at it a lot of this would you walk
into the low no we started with no
script with nothing and we did this in
seven weeks and seven weeks there were a
lot of folks that were helping out and
that wanted to be a part of this and we
were able to do it in seven weeks
because we did have a lot of people on
board all right and I think by design
who really planned it you know our
distribution of labor was very clear and
it did take it was a lot of time to
sacrifice for the students because we
would meet during regular class time but
we would also meet in the eighth in the
evenings after school so it was though
they were in a regular show alright with
regular rehearsal times after after
class and we would also meet on weekends
we didn't necessarily we heard most
weekends we didn't rehearse most
weekends was spent you know coming
together with food we bring food and we
just eat and spend a Sunday afternoon
talking about the show and looking at
films and documentaries on water and
just being reflective about what we'll
be doing that was
you plan or remounting this reduction in
tax I do not know I do not I'm on to
what other thing
I
I was wondering what that that is a
composite character okay I can tell you
that Ibrahim is many characters okay
Ibrahim as many characters because
guinea worm and Ghana at that time was
second only to the Sudan there were many
many people in particularly northern
Ghana who were getting getting one all
right and being a donkey cart seller
based on the interviews of donkey
sellers that I met during the decade of
field work that I was doing there worth
telling the similar story okay and again
it was a matter of personalizing
individualizing that story in the
character of Hebrew him so that it
became you know someone that opened up
as we talked about earlier a kind of
path toward empathy in the best
tradition of that words so it wasn't you
know just there are a lot of folks
selling water off the backs of donkeys
and there are a lot of folks getting get
getting worm but what if one identity
tells that story a very personal way so
that was the experiment
can you explain how there was once water
in pipes and now there isn't what's the
kind i think the question is what's a
economic and political and social reason
for the pipes to no longer be flowing if
that the infrastructure that's a really
hard that's a really really hard
question but i will try to answer it
this way during the 70's there was a
really difficult drought in ghana
alright and there was also a problem
with the oil crisis I that brought the
value of the CD down very low and there
was also a concern right after World War
two alright so I know it sounds very is
still very confusing to me because it's
a compilation of things what that grew
out of this notion of structural
adjustment alright so with the economy
just kind of bottoming out during the
late 70s and early 80's all right with
the depletion of the CD with the
problems of structural adjustment where
the notion of public water that was
connected to kind of accountability with
the public water system in Gotham that
there became movements toward
privatization where the forestry then
became open to private businesses that
had a very negative effect on ponds and
streams because many people would get
their pond
would go to the water and get get the
water from these certain pounds and
strange the other thing that would
happen is there was this large migration
from the rural areas into the cities
that was not able to service this this
very heightened population of people all
right and that also retallick on the
water system so it was a combination I
think of the economy changing from
structural adjustment it was a
combination of the CD and the value of
the gun and currency reaching a bottom
it was also the problem of folks not
having the kind of employment they had
before and there was a kind of
middle-class force in Ghana that was
able to support through taxation and
through a kind of distribution of labor
that was able to then reinvigorate the
way the the pipe structure worked and
but let me just say this one of the most
difficult problems was this large
migration pattern that happened from the
villages to the cities where there was
one piped water source it began then
when people in the in certain village
areas would go to the pond the time
wasn't contaminated because of the
forestry issues but in the cities all
right and it was toward the the late 80s
one of those central pipes broke all
right the infrastructure was not in
place
kindly was not in place to repair that
when i was there in 1998 it still had
not been repaired so they were working
off one major pipe into the city all
right that was responsible i don't
remember the figures i had them in the
book but i don't remember what they were
where you had to central pipes that were
to populate say six large communities
all right now that one pipe was doing
that work so people the water was not
getting to these areas so it was a
breakdown of infrastructure was
overcrowding of the city's it was
privatization of forestry and the life
I'm sorry invention that performances
metadata as opposed to medical
metaphoric and the idea that it's also
process of translation and you obviously
want it seems to have obviously gone
through a process translation is your
company at sector seven weeks there are
your students they are looking at this
material or engaging these films and I
would imagine they were they were
identifying the things that they saw is
important in those and the stories in
your field minutes that you shared with
them would you be able to talk us
through that moment that type of
translation where they identify
something is important they want to
bring out something that's important
possibly you looking at you go well
that's not what's really important about
this story something else is or just a
process of translation with those
students engaging to tears when I shared
with you today more those scenes that I
wrote ok so the scenes that you saw
today where the scenes that I wrote
based on my field work so I think the
question comes out of that as well
because you have not because I you have
not read or seen some of the work that
the students did so that would give you
a probably a greater idea of how the
students were watching these sounds and
reading these materials and we were in
rehearsal and talking about my fieldwork
and they were talking about their
experiences with water all right so the
process came about this way all right
they had materials they had an abundance
of research materials just as I had an
abundance of research materials that
were fieldwork materials all right we
together would talk through that they
would ask me questions I would ask them
questions all right they were journaling
every day during this process all right
just as I was journaling every day so
the way that they were describing the
rehearsals and asking questions through
their journals and speaking back to some
of the document documentaries they saw
those were in the jury
so a lot of this performance came out of
their journal entries all right and then
through the rehearsal role-playing games
looking at certain objects in the room
all right and giving voice to those
objects in the rule and what if those
objects were transported from Chapel
Hill to West Africa how would it stink
differently some of that made it into
the performance we would when we
listened to most deaths world water how
would you then perform your own song or
your own poem or your own spoken word
piece that represents some of the stuff
that you've read and some of the films
that you've looked at how would you
speak to that as you have you know just
engulfed yourself in all of this
literature how would you cast that to
spoken word all right and let's just
play with that just extemporaneously
right now and we would do that in
rehearsal and some of that made it into
the piece all right if you were to be a
character this is at a cocktail party if
we were at can you think of a scene
where people talk about water in ways
that are completely antithetical to the
message we want to bring in the show
what would that scene look like well it
might be a cocktail party well how can
we play off of that so that it becomes
almost hyperbolic okay and so in
rehearsal they were playing off this
notion of the cocktail party and what
you know the super-rich are very rich or
the super uninformed might say about
these things all right that ended up
making it to the performance when there
was a piece that I wrote that
represented a water activist and as I
was reading it to them we were I was
asking them what's not clear here what
do we need to do you take this and we
work it but I want you to think about we
working it through dance what would a
dance of this speech look like and so
you see I think Maria is there
side down with their legs up so there
were three women that made this stance
when I asked them about what can you can
you can you articulate your first water
story what would that gesture look like
and they said and let's think of it
abstractly they said well let's think
about water just an infinite number of
plastic water bottles being in a box and
I'm telling you my first water story as
I'm telling you my first water story I'm
opening up this big box and each bus was
decorated by the students and the way
they wanted to and at the audience they
don't know what's in this box so they're
opening up this box and what they find
they look and the next thing you know
they're just throwing these water
bottles all over the stage all right and
they're thinking that there's somewhere
between their first memory of water and
what happens now when they drink water
out of a water bottle all right and it
gets it looks but it feels almost
fabricated as they lose touch with that
all right it becomes mechanized in a way
it becomes a commodified in a way when
their first memories of water were water
when their father was washing one story
was the father was washing her hair
another story was being caught in the
rain all right but this is all water
water this bottled and water this part
of your childhood so they thought we
will open up this box of memories and
what this box of memories really becomes
are these plastic water bottles so the
plastic water bottles are now all over
the stage and then we said but what is
your real first memory of water that you
can't remember being in the womb so the
students and now on the stage some of
them are almost like in fetal position
some of them are not but they're lying
on the stage under all of these water
bottles that is suggestive of the ocean
that suggestive of birth the birth canal
that is suggestive of just this perhaps
imaginary utopian moment of peace and
water but there but they're surrounded
by the water bottles okay so all of that
it's amazing
hang as you know what can happen when
you have all of this material that's
talking about a particular idea and it
takes you in the form in which you're
dealing with this idea the forms are
multiple from pictures to songs to you
know theoretical articles to propaganda
you know all of these forms around this
one idea and the act of translating not
only the subject but translating the
forms out of which this this particular
subject takes place that is also a part
of translating your own memory bank you
know where you can join with the text to
another level of translation where you
have to think about how does this now
become a three-dimensional experience on
stage that is about the aesthetic and
when you have 11 people doing this it
will take you in all kinds of creative
directions thank you so much
you